Я Тарас Тополя лідер гурту Антитіла
батько трьох дітей Мене звати Ірина
цибух я переменник добровольчого
батальйону госпітальєри
актор
директор державного підприємства
Кримський дім
кудрява і я військовослужбовець
найкращої бригади швидкого реагування
Національної гвардії України Мене звати
жорін Максим я
захищаю країну з 14-го року мій позивний
Яра я військово-морської піхоти на війні
ми опинилися в перший день коли почалась
повномасштабна війна у мене не було
іншого уявлення про те які можуть
допомогти ніж бути Медиком на передовій
питання
чи не йти після першої гарячої фази
війни 14-15 року
дуже добре розуміла що
Росія повторить наступ завжди чітко знав
що я маю бути там де я буду захищати
свою батьківщину своїх близьких свою
націю я тут на Вій
ні кадрові тому що це мій вибір і моя
покликання За останні півроку Україна
отримала величезну кількість ран які
будуть ще довго загоюватися Дуже щиро
сподіваюся що кожен усвідомлює
Хто насправді наш брат і друг багато хто
прийняв що війна - це наша доля і якщо
ми хочемо існувати Ми повинні боротися
за себе повинні вміти захищати себе і
повинні вміти солідаризуватися єдине в
чому У нас війна не змінила наших
цінностях
і в нашому прагненні до свободи
незалежного вільного майбутнього через
10 років я хотів побачити
сильну сучасну цивілізовану європейську
країну
поверненим Кримом Донецьком луганському
та пам'ять про усіх колеглих полонених
що в країні було верховенство права щоб
у наших батьків були
згідно Старість сильно хочеться жити оце
своє класне цивільне життя їздить на
сицилію пити вино на Подолі зустрічатися
з друзями я сумую за цим життям і сильно
сподіваюся що вдасться повернутися через
10 років Я впевнений що наші
діти
продовжать те що почали ми Я дуже хочу
після перемоги
передати нашу Україну нашим дітям і
внукам кращому стані ніж її залишили нам
всім цивільним який сьогодні можливо
почали відчувати в тому
невпевненість слабкість або навіть
падати духом я би порадив Подивіться на
українських військових
Пригадайте як героїчно захищали
Маріуполь коли опускаються руки
коли
стає дуже складно
Дозвольте собі відпочити
але потім з новими силами
робіть все що можете з тим що маєте ЗСУ
в Національну гвардію
Кожен з нас має потенціал боротися за
свою країну тому що наша країна дуже нам
важить вона для нас є основою бо нашу
жити будь-яке життя якщо немає Куди
повернутись і немає його де жити я не
хочу вас обманювати легше найближчим
часом не буде Але я точно знаю що ми
вистаємо я пам'ятаю півроку тому
в березні в кінці лютого в березні
біля Маріуполя було дуже холодно холод
який врізався в шкіру при розстав до неї
були миті коли я сумнівалася що
ми і наша держава дуже веду 24 серпня до
дня я Незалежності
але ось ми дожили Я хочу привітати всіх
українців з Днем Незалежності
Це сьогодні не просто слова не просто
дати не просто свято сьогодні саме
незалежність це символ того заради чого
щодня ми боремося та проливаємо кров я
би хотіла попросити всіх українців жити
своє найкраще життя бо воно в нас одне
легенди і міфи
що це створюють прямо зараз тут в
Україні ми всі ми з моєю коханою якесь
Бажаємо вам
і кохання в першу чергу тому що це
надзвичайно мотивує
з Днем незалежності України вас Ми
переможемо ми вже перемогли тому що ми
не зламалися і тому що ми боремося з
Днем Незалежності пам'ятаєте якою ціною
вона нам вдається будьте сильними і
йдемо до перемоги з Днем Незалежності
Бережіть себе Слава Україні Героям слава